because it is christmas today as far as
we're concerned
uh we thought we'd indulge in a very
special holiday tradition
and read a christmas tale this one's
slightly updated it's called
twas a while before christmas and um
well as you'll see it's been uh
updated for our current circumstances
here we go
gather round kids twas a while before
christmas
perhaps a bit longer i just traded my
lexapro
for something much stronger our children
are feral
their bedtimes whenever we're wiping
down postmates delivered by trevor
the stockings were hung on the peloton
with care i know what you're thinking
but we use it
i swear the west coast was burning
and the politics were mean the mask list
rose up
and spread covid 19. we marched and held
signs and made calls to our reps
we all joined antifa just to get in our
steps
we clung to our tv sets binging with
shame
from each streaming service we all know
their names
on netflix on hulu on amazon prime
should i sign up for quibby you know
what i'm fine
when out on the lawn there arose such a
clatter contact free pizza
so i could get fatter away to the window
i flew like a flash
leave it on the porch take your tip yes
it's cash
instead there stood santa who was
looking quite round
but listen who hasn't packed on a few
pounds i went in for a hug
and he shunned my advances he said sorry
bud but i can't take any chances
then he left in a flurry of anti-back
spray
some n95s where the cookies once lay
he yelled everything's canceled thanks
to covet 19. i'll be back next year if
we have a vaccine
i stared at the clouds with a glimmer of
hope my cnn news alert replied
and said nope i dropped to my knees
wagging fist to the sky
merry christmas to all into all
a good cry
that's just lovely anyway
[Laughter]
thanks a lot dad no problem
that's gonna kill at the office
christmas party
that's yours to keep